Hey guys, today we're experimenting to see what happens when you throw a cap dart at gasoline
because you asked for it.
These cap darts are super simple to make, they use a #6 machine screw and some of these kids' cap gun
caps to put over the top and turn them into exploding-tipped blow darts. This gives the
dart the ability that when the dart hits the ground, it makes a loud sharp snap. These cap darts are super easy to make, they're super
fun to play with, and they're not really that dangerous until today because our friend "landon main"
asks "The real question is can it light gasoline", so we're going to find out. (Cracking) Got my trusty
fire extinguisher hope we don't have to use that today, douse it with a little bit more gasoline
just so it's kind of refreshed and ready and I'm going to put this really far away. The first test
I'm going to try is just dropping it from here, let's just see what happens, so let's give it a try here
3... 2... 1... (Cracking) Now did you see that? There was actually a spark (Slow motion crack) of fire
on there, but I didn't actually see the gasoline light, which is amazing because this brick is actually pretty
well soaked with gasoline. (Continuous cracking) Nothing! All right so here's the cap dart if you take
a look at the cap here, you probably noticed there's no real noticeable damage, it's not cracked open and
I think most of the blast shot back upward towards the top of the cap. We actually need to blast
forward out of the cap, so let's try it one more time, but this time, let's throw it quite a bit harder to see
if we can get the sparks to fly forward. (Cracking) Whoa, There it is! (Ignition). Here's the cap you can
actually see it did blast through. That is different than the first one was. Ok so one thing you need to
know about using gasoline on the road is something we learned right now. Look down here at what's
happening to the asphalt. Apparently, gasoline heats the road, ok so don't try this at home!
We're going to find a little bit safer place to do the next experiments.
Now that we got a little puddle of gasoline, I'm going to hit this hard and hope that it goes off, so we are
are going to try
(Continuous cracking)
(Slow motion crack)
OK so we're dealing with gasoline, it's a volatile liquid that is supposed to react to sparks, but we're
throwing exploding cap darts, you can see that the sparks aren't coming out, so why is this not going
off?
(Cracking)
Dude, I really want this to light off. I really do. I'm getting a little discouraged
Ok, so we're kind of thinking like most of the sparks are flying to the back, we might need to prepare
these a little bit to encourage the sparks to come out the front. I'm going to take these scissors, and
cut a little bit of a hole in the tip there to make it a little bit easier access to that thing when it
explodes. Let's see if that makes a difference.
(Cracking)
Oh, I missed it, but it worked!
Dude, I think we're up to something
We have to see it in slow motion
(Ignition) Oh, dude, I totally missed, but that worked perfectly!
That looks really cool.
Let's do this one more time.
Oh, I didn't prepare this!
(Cracking)
Yes! Yeah
(Slow motion cracking)
I have created fire!
Not really the fire I want to cook a hot-dog although
Boom, like Magic!
(Ignition)
So now that we've got to figure out how to do it by hand, lets take things up a notch and try it with our
laser-guided blowgun
(Ignition)
Alright guys, so in conclusion, I think we finally cracked the code on how to make these things go off.
It's not by throwing it as hard as you can, it's by trimming the edges so we can direct the sparks into
the gasoline, so now that we're getting these things to work 100% of the time. I want to see your
comments below on what kind of things we should light up with them. Thanks so much for joining me
for this experiment and while you're waiting for the next one, I've got a lot more videos you can still
check out at thekingofrandom.com. I'll see you in the next one
Hey, what's up guys, I made this video because you asked for it, and i'm taking more requests right now.
So what do you want for me to do next? Put your wackiest ideas in the comments and let's see what
fun we can have in the next video. I'll see you there.
Patreon